here's another thing that could be
pitted in that competition so imagine
you had people who men who could confer
benefit and who were incapable of
inflicting inflicting cost and men who
could confer benefit but were capable of
inflicting cost i think you'd see
winners on that side because of that
free rider problem and so and that ties
into what we'll discuss in relationship
to the dark triad because
because
there's some
mystery about why women seem to be
attracted to these so-called dark triad
traits
and i would say that they're using them
as
insufficient markers for the ability to
or the acquisition of status so and
narcissists capitalize on that right
because a narcissist looks confident
and lots of confident people are
competent but some confident people
aren't competent but they can fool you
and then i think the other explanation
is that if you had to choose between a
benefit confer who could punish free
riders and one who couldn't you should
pick the former
uh one
who could one who could who could deal
with free riders who could and would had
the capability to
and so
you see you see this sort of thing i
really like the disney movie beauty and
the beast
i think it i think they got it right and
so there's gaston in that movie and he's
a narcissist but he's he has physical
prowess like he can't understand why
he's not the guy but he's narcissistic
and then there's the beast who's a beast
but he's tameable
and so he he can be a benefit conferrer
and he has the capacity to inflict cost
yes yeah and and and the two are often
correlated in nature so like for example
if you have physical prowess or athletic
ability then you have both the ability
to
confer benefits you know in the form of
say protection or hunting skills but
also the ability to inflict costs by you
know okay so let's talk about the dark
triad then in relationship to
agreeableness because the doc do you
want to just tell everybody what the
dark triad is first so that we're all on
the same page yeah so so the dark triad
um
i think this was originally named by uh
one of your canadian psychology
colleagues del paula so the ubc
and it the dark triad originally was uh
uh three of triad but it's narcissism
machiavellianism and psychopathy so
where narcissism is typically marked by
a sense of grandiosity
a sense of
entitlement
they think they're the most intelligent
the smartest uh the most attractive the
most charming the most skilled et cetera
uh
were in the words of one of my former
graduate students they think they're hot
but they're not
uh so uh and i think i think there's a
way in which
people do have the ability to assess
whether that
uh high self-esteem
is uh warranted or not you know because
we have even words in our language for
things like arrogant you know that kind
of uh
[Applause]
con out someone who is uh thinks that
they're
more beautiful or more intelligent or
more capable than they actually are so
that's narcissism but the entitlement is
i think a critical component of
narcissism where they feel i i'm so
great i'm i deserve a larger share of
the pie including the sexual pie if we
when we get to the issue of sexual
conflict and sexual coercion uh
machiavellianism
i mean that stems from the the the
prince of i can't remember how many
hundreds of years ago that was written
but um it's basically people who pursue
an exploitative social strategy so they
can they they are when we were talking
about reciprocity earlier they will
feign
reciprocity fame
being uh good reciprocators but then
they will
they will cheat and so these are the the
liars the cheaters
right so if the if the patriarchy was
based on exploitative power then dark
triad personality traits would be
adaptively and practically useful and
desirable
if that was the case yeah if that if
that was the case yes yes okay now and
that gets complicated because one of the
things your research has indicated is
that there is a manner in which women
are attracted to people who manifest
dark triad traits
yeah i would say i would add the
qualifier that it tends to be younger
women so
teenagers or women in their early 20s
women as they mature and get more
experience on the mating market tend to
be less attracted to these
dark triad characters okay so here's a
here's a hypothesis
it's not that easy to distinguish the
willingness to use casual power and and
control
from competence when you're not very
experienced and so the dark triad types
can feign status related competence and
they can ensnare naive women yes yeah
that's right
they also
have some qualities that women genuinely
do desire so the they tend to like the
narcissists tend to put themselves at
the center of attention and one of the
things we know about status hierarchies
is that
uh the attention structure is very
important that is the high status people
tend to be those to whom the most people
pay them the most attention
uh and so women are drawn i i one
anecdote a female colleague of mine very
intelligent evolutionary psychologist
said went to a conference and found
herself very attracted to the organizer
of the conference and then six months
later
she he she encountered him and he was
just a normal attendee at the conference
and she didn't find him very attractive
she went what was i thinking but what it
was is he was he was at the center of
the attention structure well the the
attention structure is an unbelievably
reliable indicator of what's valuable
because we don't devote our visual
attentive resources to anything that
isn't of singular value in the
environment and so that's why we get
precisely why we compete for attention
it's also an extremely valuable resource
absolutely so i mean a valuable and
limited resource it's finite and so
really at every moment in time we're
making decisions about what to allocate
our attention to i read a funny study
once you might be aware of this where
monkeys i think they were green monkeys
but i'm not sure
were shown photographs of other members
of their troop and they gazed much
longer at the high status individuals in
the photographs
so and you know and then you think about
that too there's there's something
really interesting about that because
imagine that that compulsion to attend
to what acquired status or let's say
competence status is accompanied in
human beings by a profound instinct to
imitate
right that's right because um i mean
we are we are social learners and one of
the things that we try to do is to
emulate those who have qualities that
are associated with status you know and
and that that gets into you know and
those those vary from group to group and
subgroup to subgroup and in the modern
environment we have this uh kind of a
weird situation of a proliferation of
status hierarchies you know where you
can be the i don't know the top
social influencer where the only thing
you have going for you is i don't know a
line of makeup or something like that or
nothing at all i mean paris hilton was
like famous for being famous
and so she got a lot of attention but
there was no
no no real benefit there but you know we
have like uh you can if you're if you
play video games for example which which
i i don't happen to but uh their status
hierarchies within those you know the
most skilled video game player the most
skilled football player rugby player
tennis player yeah well it's a good
thing you know that we can create all
these competence hierarchies because
what it means is that diverse talents
have the opportunity to acquire the
status that might also all
alternatively
entice them to violence let's say
because that is associated with status
inequality and so one of the solutions
to status in co inequalities diverse
games of competence as diverse range as
possible
yeah
and and that's i mean and that's
definitely a a good thing uh because i
mean if if there was just one status
hierarchy then that means um i mean
status is in inherently a relative
uh gauge by relative metric you know so
and
if you're the number one
no one else can be the number one uh but
you know if you can be the best uh
scholar the best writer the best uh
world of warcraft player the best tennis
player these multiple status hierarchies
gives more peop give more people the
opportunity to to gain in status another
another argument against the patriarchy
as unitary idea right well which
patriarchy do you mean do you mean
like the evil coalition of plumbers
which is a joke i've made before
it's like you know that's power is it
plumbers really no they're not organized
in terms of their success by which
plumber is the meanest and the toughest
it's that's not how it works at all
right so yeah absolutely and and i mean
that that gets into the
the issue of
uh oh there there are large pools of men
who are at the bottom of the status
hierarchy and
um who uh who who don't have the
qualities that that women desire and so
are they really oppressing
uh women there's this interesting
uh
cap there's an interesting photo that i
think got captioned but it's too very
elegant women with designer handbags and
they're walking by a guy who's like
fixing uh the the tar in the street he's
a street worker fixing the tar and as
they walk by this guy who's groveling on
the ground
they say stop oppressing me
right
so
anyway right right well i wanted to talk
to you a bit more about the dark triad
issue too because
there's a mystery in it and i think it's
one that corrupts psychology to some
degree research psychology oh yes okay
oh just so we didn't mention the third
one oh yeah
the third element of the dark hair which
is psychopathy uh and and you probably
have a deeper understanding of
psychopathy than i do but um
one of the hallmarks is a lack of
empathy that is most normal humans have
an empathy circuit that we we feel
compassion if someone gets hurt or if a
pet gets injured or a child falls down
and skins a knee we feel a sense of
compassion for the suffering of other
people but psychopaths don't it's like
they might laugh
uh if someone gets hurt and and uh so
that empathy circuit seems to be severed
uh and also one of the hallmarks seems
to be that they're
um not responsive to punishment
um that they're more oriented toward
reward wardens that punishing them
doesn't tend to change their behavior
it isn't obvious that they have an
empathy for their future selves
right so punishments like well
you know part of the reason that you
react to punishment is because you don't
want your future self to be punished
again but you have to care about that
before that works
right right yeah that gets the the issue
of uh steepness the steepness of future
discounting yes exactly exactly yeah
they uh grab for all the gusto right now
and don't think about the future
consequences
so so one of the things that
one of the big five personality traits
that the dark triad is most associated
with is agreeableness low agreeableness
and that's and i do think that research
psychologists and psychologists in
general have a kind of ethical bias in
relationship to the agreeableness
dimension
you know and and it it and of course
women are higher in trade agreeableness
that men right reliably it's about half
a standard deviation it's one of the
biggest sex differences and it's
associated with compassion and
politeness in in the work we've done
anyways and so that's empathy at least
to some degree
now the question is
what is the ethical utility of lower
agreeableness right because you'd think
what would interfere possibly with
sharing
right because if you're more
compassionate and more compassionate
more empathic you're going to feel the
hunger of other people and you'd be more
motivated to to care for them let's say
but it's also possible that that low
agreeableness has
something to do with well perhaps
hunting prowess that might be part of it
but it also might be part of the
solution to the free rider problem
and so women are in a conundrum with
agreeableness right because they need a
mate who's agreeable enough so they can
bond with them and that will care for
their children and it cares in general
but they need someone who's disagreeable
enough so that they're capable let's say
of dealing with free riders and that's
right yeah so one way of saying that is
uh agreeable
with respect to them but the potential
for being disagreeable with respect to
those others when they need to be
punished or they need to ward off an
attacker right and you can see that
that's a real tight line to walk down
you know and part of what constrains
agreeableness let's say from a
temperamental perspective so if you're
low in agreeableness let's say well
you're less empathic you're more
competitive you're rougher blunter
tougher you know emo what would you say
at least with regards to the at the
compassion you show to others
um and so what what helps modulate that
well some of that would be
conscientiousness and so in the dark
triad types you see low
conscientiousness as well you know
really low agreeable high conscientious
types are quite interesting because you
can trust them because they'll do their
duty but they're very blunt and direct
and harsh and that can be helpful as
well because they'll tell you unpleasant
truths even if they hurt your feelings
so there's some utility in that so you
can imagine that agreeableness can be
modified let's say by conscientiousness
so that and that takes the the
psychopathy edge off it because low
agreeableness and low conscientiousness
that's that's a rough combination
yes and so yeah yeah yeah because
there's nothing constraining it and so
women are attracted to some degree to
the lower agreeable types and i think
that accounts for the bad boy paradox
that you described at least in part
and maybe it takes further experience
and and wisdom on the part of judicious
women to see where they can get the
disagreeableness that's necessary but it
has to be hemmed in by something like
well conscientiousness uh yeah other
personality traits like
conscientiousness yeah i mean one other
reason that i think that women are
attracted to the dark triad at least the
younger women is
that they're often
risk takers so um they will do things
like um motorcycle jumping or
ski jumping or take physical risk
speeding in their their cars or
uh and and so the kind of daredevil uh
mentality and women at least younger
women find that exciting but i wonder if
they can i wonder if they confuse that
with trait openness
right because the open types are going
to experiment they're going to try lots
of different things and that that
daredevil you know i don't care
might be easily
not easily distinguished from the
capacity to engage in creative
problem-solving pursuits you know and
and perhaps with courage as well
yeah yeah so i think i think
courage and also
one of the
you know that people who take risks
often in in fact have
the ability to afford those risks uh if
if you will so for example
you know doing some uh dangerous
athletic feat if if you're not an
athletic person you're gonna fail at
that and so in some sense some of these
uh daredevil
uh behaviors i think are kind of cues
that you have the ability to afford to
take those risks but but these guys
these high dark guys are absolutely
disastrous as long-term mates um so that
they might be exciting for sure i mean
that's why i think that women as they
mature
uh stop being attracted to these guys
especially if they're looking for a
long-term mate because these are guys
they're the dark red they're more likely
to cheat uh they're more likely to
seduce and abandon them they're more
likely to engage in deceptive
uh mating tactics uh and so and so they
tend to be big trouble when it comes to
long-term mating
yeah well it also looks like they value
themselves greatly and you know
sometimes people value themselves
greatly and so they have high mate
desirability in in your in your
terminology or maybe some little
corruption of your terminology and again
i think the dark triad guys mimic that
it's like i'm so good i can afford to
you know
distribute my sexual prowess wherever i
see fit and there's some some of that
happens as men rise incompetence
hierarchies as well well yes and it
happens with women when they rise in
their higher